in 1983 NASA sent Sally Ride into space
as the first American woman to ever
enter into orbit in her in the leadup to
her launch the engineering team at Nasa
was very hard at work to ensure that
everything would go off without a hitch
so at some point before the big day the
all male team came to ride and to ask
her if a sufficient number of t tampons
for a weeklong mission was 100 100
tampons uh ride simply responded no that
would not be the correct number uh when
pressed for more information she told
them that they could cut that number in
half and it would still be way too many
um I love this story for a variety of
reasons um one of them is that I just
find it fun to imagine what led up to
the moment where they finally like
landed on the number 100 like were they
all sitting around around table like how
long were they talking these are
Engineers did they do like research on
the absorbency per tampon and do like
back of the envelope
calculations um and another reason I
love this story is I think it's really
um well suited to communicate this idea
that even the most well-intentioned
group of people uh will often do a
laughable job of trying to meet the
needs of another group that they are not
part of I think about how much smoother
that process would have gone if there
was just one menstrating person on that
engineering team this really drives home
for me the idea that to truly make
something that meets someone's needs
someone who has those needs themselves
must be part of the development
process and as you may have guessed from
the title of my talk I'm not here to
talk about tampons um so in recent years
there's been a growing uh awareness
understanding and acceptance of the
importance of technology
accessibility um and as we all know
technology doesn't just create itself um
data doesn't analyze itself or you know
at least not yet um so we have this
process of an initial developer
contributor maintainer um who supports
the creation of a tool or who is doing
the data science themselves uh so they
then produce an output whether that's an
app or a dashboard a piece of software
um and then that subsequently ends in
the hands of a stakeholder or end user
and in most of this dialogue so far we
tend to focus at the end on that end
user uh and we gener do this by focusing
in on the output stage we do this by
asking ourselves questions like can
someone who is colorblind distinguish
the features of this graph or have I
included sufficient alt text for someone
who requires non-visual access to this
information but I'm here to insist that
this is the wrong place for us to be
focusing if our goal is to avoid being
like that all male engineering team at
Nasa instead of focusing primarily on
the experience of the enduser we need to
look further upstream and divert our
attention toward the experience of the
programmer or data scientist we need to
work to reduce unnecessary barriers for
disabled coders and continue to support
uh their ability to continue to use um
and contribute to open source
projects and so to do this we need to
think about the tools packages languages
programs Etc the data scientists and
developers depend on in their daily work
we need to figure out how we can improve
the accessibility of these tools so that
we can ensure fewer structural barriers
to the continued participation and
flourishing of disabled members of the
open source community in the remainder
of my talk I'm going to discuss some
simple steps that can be taken to begin
improving the accessibility of of Open
Source projects importantly these are
steps that can be taken by absolutely
anyone and don't require having any
having any depth of knowledge in
accessibility or web accessibility as a
result of that I'm not going to get into
any of the particularly technical
aspects of Technology accessibility um
in the link to my slides which I'll
bring up again at the end um I also have
a collection of resources that I am also
continuing to add to so if you come back
in the following weeks there's going to
be more and more
resources so imagine that you are
renovating your kitchen and everything's
going perfectly until you come across
some issue so you do some Googling you
try to figure out what's going on and
eventually you think you figured it out
and it seems like you can solve it
yourself if you just get your hands on a
specific power tool so you go online and
spend some significant effort
researching and selecting the right tool
making sure it has specific set of
features and capabilities that you need
you order it and unfortunately once it
arrives it has plug type f which is used
commonly throughout much of Europe but
you're located in the US and therefore
your Outlets only accommodate type A or
B plugs you it would have been great if
this information was included in the
product description but it wasn't uh in
fact it's not present in the description
of almost any tool that you can find
online so your best bet is to just keep
buying new ones and trying them to see
if they work if you're thinking that
this sounds like it would be an
incredibly frustrating way to get
something done you're right um and it's
also the reality for many disabled data
scientists and programmers when it comes
to trying out open source Tools in order
to solve their programming problems in
this metaphor we should be thinking of
the power tool as a package or IDE or
tool um and the plug outlet
compatibility is is accessible ility
right so it's it's somebody it's the IDE
that someone wants to work in and the
outlet is their screen reader and if you
don't in a lot of instances they have no
way of knowing whether or not the two
will work together until after they've
downloaded it and tried it um and unlike
an incompatible plug you can't just like
go on Amazon and buy a travel adapter
and just circumvent the whole thing with
accessibility so this brings me to the
first thing we can do which is create
accessibility docs what I say when I
what I mean when I say this is creating
documentation that helps individuals
quickly assess whether something meets
not only their technical requirements
but crucially also their accessibility
requirements Um this can look like a lot
of different things like just a
highlevel status of the accessibility of
the tool um importantly you can just say
that you don't know uh even it is
unknown how compatible this is with
screen readers or we haven't done any
Research into the accessibility of this
is significantly more informative than
saying nothing at all um you can also
create start creating a list of known
accessibility problems and you can
highlight accessibility features some of
these might be things that are specific
to accessibility but there are probably
some that already exist like keyboard
shortcuts or various opt options for
error handling so once you establish
what you do already know or not know
about accessibility you're going to want
to set up a way to get further
information so you're going to create a
forum for feedback um one of the easiest
ways to do this is to create an
accessibility issue template or label um
and this serves a variety of purposes
one is it serves a really valuable
signal under status quo um when already
facing a lot of other barriers for their
participation a disabled programmer has
to then try to assess whether or not
it's actually worth it to put the time
and effort to create a valuable
reproducible example because it's not
clear whether or not the maintainers of
that project actually care and want to
fix this I would hope that everybody
that's in this room is in the group of
people people that would want to but
there is still a lot of ableism within
Tech and there are a lot of people who
think it's really just not that
important to focus on so this gets you
information because now people know okay
it's worth it to try to put in you know
this
information um it also elevates the
importance of accessibility and helps us
with culture change so we can start
thinking of problems with accessibility
as bugs and not as add-on features that
we think of after the initial
development of the product is complete
and it's crucial for identif Ying issues
that are specific to the particular tool
some issues with accessibility are going
to come up again and again and again um
but some are just going to be really
Niche and you're not going to know um
unless you're told about your specific
project now if you're thinking that
these examples are like cool but they're
mostly just setting the stage for
improving accessibility and you want to
start doing something to actually
improve things or maybe you're not a
maintainer of a project and you want to
be a contributor but you don't really
feel like you have as much leeway to do
some of these ear steps um then uh I
suggest that you work on improving
technical documentation and okay I know
writing documentation isn't exactly most
people's favorite parts of the job um
you know maybe there'd be few people in
the room if I had highlighted that this
talk was mostly going to be about
documentation uh in the abstract um but
I'm hoping that we can manufacture some
excitement by um displaying just how
huge of a barrier poorly accessible
documentation can be so let's say you're
trying to get an overview of some sort
of complex process in order to better
understand something you're building or
trying to debug so you bring up
documentation for say con the conceptual
architecture of this Tool uh I've done
that for an actual technical
documentation page um and I'd like for
us to take a moment to hear what the
experience would be like with a screen
reader uh it's an important note that um
the captions here are mine which I added
for accessibility for everyone in the
room this wouldn't actually be part of
the screen reader
experience
oh I forgot to turn mute off one
second
um I have to pull out of that
because it's not let's see it's plugged
in we tested beforehand main landmark
the following diagram shows the
relationship cool sorry let me get back
in
there link found an error report link
download the manual link found an error
main landmark the following diagram
shows the relationships link graphic
open stack conceptual
architecture so H you might think if
this is all the information you have
maybe this documentation still under
construction I mean all it really said
is that you know this is a
representation and it's a graphic of
conceptual architecture you don't know
if it's an icon or a logo or something
actually important now I'm cited so I
can go see what the page actually looks
like and for those of us in the room and
online who are cited let's take a visual
look at what the page looks like link
found an error well
well okay so that's a lot of information
that wasn't included in the screen
reader experience uh there is a giant
diagram on the screen that is incredibly
complex and would probably take me a few
minutes to digest visually um and the
alt text for that is just graphic of
open stack architecture which is
obviously pretty insufficient so this
brings me to the first thing we can do
which is to improve alt text um and I'd
like to correct a fundamental
misunderstanding many people have about
the purpose of alt text if you're able
to remember just this you're already on
your way to writing much more accessible
text um and it's that alt text's purpose
is to serve the function of the image in
place of the image it's not to describe
an image uh so a really good test
without becoming proficient in screen
reader use is to use the plain text
version of your documentation don't
render your markdown use just that are
you able to get the information out of
it that you need if not your alt text is
insufficient and you need to go back and
try
again um we should also be working on
making sure that any hyperlink text is
informative uh so frequently you might
see something like to learn more about a
really cool package click here where
click here is the link um many people
who use screen readers will cycle
through all the links on a page to find
the external resource they need which
means they encounter it without the um
rest of the sentence um yeah the context
of the rest of the sentence so they
would actually encounter something like
this click here or here which obviously
doesn't provide sufficient information
and so you would want what you would
want is something more like learn more
about a really cool package where that
is the linked
text you should also be using a
consistent logical heading structure um
you're going to want to use actual
heading elements and not just stylizing
the text um and make sure you don't skip
level levels of heading hierarchy if you
want something to not be as big as the
you know level two heading um then you
should be using CSS to change the visual
appearance rather than just skipping
down to an H3 or an H4 um this is
because people using screen readers
can't visually scan and skim the page
the way that I can using my eyes um and
so if they don't have headings to give
them an idea of where they are in the
page and decide whether they want to go
into that section their option is to
just listen to the entire documentation
being read out verbatim um from top to
bottom which is pretty terrible um this
also provides really important cognitive
scaffolding for even cited developers
especially for individuals who might be
recovering from a head injury who are
neurod Divergent who experiencing brain
fog as a result of chronic fatigue or
maybe you just got really terrible sleep
last night and it's helpful to have
documentation that doesn't
suck you should also be using clear and
concise language um breaking up walls of
text where you can writing in short
sentences writing in the positive form
using active voice these are all things
we're probably somewhat familiar
with so to sort of summarize our points
there are a few things that we can do to
start improving the accessibility of
Open Source projects one we can create
accessibility
documentation um and this will allow
people to better assess whether um
something meets their Technical and
accessibility requirements we can create
a forum for feedback um using GitHub
issue templates or something similar and
we can improve our tech technical
documentation so with the last bit of
time that we have I'd like to invite
everyone in the room to take a moment
and think what's a small specific action
you can take in the next 24 to 48 hours
to go and start improving this in a
project that you really care about keep
in mind you don't necessarily need to be
a core maintainer many projects have
clear instructions for how to suggest a
change to documentation in fact the
first open source pool request that I
have ever opened was um one to improve
some of the alt text in jupyter
notebooks documentation this is also a
really good way if you are a core
maintainer of a project and you're
trying to get more involvement from the
community um a lot of these fixes are
really wonderful good first issues um
and so you can kind of um tackle it from
both
ends so a few ideas um I'll just sort of
pull up on the slide um and and with
issues you can make it for something
specific that you'd like to fix or just
for auditing so maybe just make an issue
for yourself to look at the alt text if
you don't know right away if any of it's
good or not um and I would suggest that
you set a reminder for yourself to make
sure you do this put it in your phone
add something to your calendar to do it
tomorrow while you're or later tonight
while you're waiting for your flight um
and I assure you you're not going to
want to forget to do this and that's
because uh as an extra piece of
motivation I have designed a custom hex
sticker associated with my talk uh but
the only way to get one is to tag me in
the comments of a poll request or an
issue or email me a screenshot something
like that so I have a limited number of
them uh if you're here in person you can
try to come find me once you're done to
get your sticker um I also know the
conference ends in a few hours and
there's a lot of people watching online
uh so if you don't if you can't find me
in person I'll make my best effort to
coordinate mailing these out to as many
people as I can until I run out uh so
thank you so much for your attention and
I look forward to getting to see the
first steps you all take to starting to
commit to
[Applause]
change thank you so much Rose I also say
if you want to do a deer or tid R
technical documentation Improvement I
will happily merge that then you can get
your
sticker um we have one question in the
slido uh what would you recommend to
incorporate into visualization packages
to make them more access and maybe is
there anything beyond just alt text yeah
um so one thing um another thing I
didn't touch on is accessibility for
people who are colorblind so one thing
that could be really great um for
visualization packages is to change
default color settings so that they are
you want to make accessibility the easy
thing to do not the hard thing to do so
everywhere we should be making it you
know easy um yeah easy to make sure you
know if you're not thinking about it you
shouldn't have to think about it um
there
uh there should also be easy ways to add
like figure text which is true of of
most um and on my external resources um
I'll be adding some more resources about
how to actually write good alt text for
visualizations uh because that's a
tricky skill to
master do you Hadley do you remember
what M uses to like like it like
overlays over the image to make sure
that it's like color blind friendly what
that thing is called there's some cool
technology there's some cool technology
to make sure that your pictures are
colorblind friendly out there they like
overlay on top of the images themselves
I don't know much about like color blind
related but since you mentioned overlays
one thing I will mention is um because I
think everybody in the disability
Community would be mad if I didn't um is
that if you're creating a website or
something like that where you're going
to host your documentation anything like
that um if you see a product there's
ones called like accessib or things like
that that are overlays that say they'll
fix your documentation or I'm sorry fix
your web accessibility uh you shouldn't
use them they're under a lot of lawsuits
right now because they actually make
accessibility worse for a lot of people
um so they people have developed plugins
to disable them because uh using them
actually makes websites more
inaccessible so if it sounds too good to
be true like a quick fix like that it
probably is are there any um existing
like any kind of templates that you can
use for creating good accessible
documentation that you know of um yes so
I have in in the external resources I
have there uh a couple different
um style guides um examples and yeah
things of that nature great thank you so
much yep thank
[Applause]
you